-♪ "Tonight Show" Cooler Heads ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" Cooler Heads ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
-And here to host the game is
legendary game-show host
Alec Baldwin!
Oh, my!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Alec, please tell us
how the game works.
-It's very simple, Jimmy.
You'll each take turns
answering multiple-choice
football-trivia questions.
Once your answer is locked in,
two coolers will be carried out
to be dumped over your heads.
-Okay.
-What?!
-If you answer --
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know much about
football -- American football?
-I'm from England.
[ Laughter ]
-If you answer correctly,
your cooler will be empty
and your opponent will be doused
with a mystery substance.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
Answer incorrectly
and you get dumped on.
-Great.
-This first question
is for Kate.
-Wait, hold on.
Why are you wearing --
-No, no, we're almost
out of time, Kate.
[ Light laughter ]
Which of these is a position
in both American football
and soccer?
"A," tight end; "B," fullback;
"C," nickelback.
I see you're cheating and
trying to look at the answer.
-I wasn't, I wasn't!
-A nickelback?
-Tight end, fullback,
or nickelback?
-I've definitely
heard of tight end.
I think it's "B."
-Okay, your answer is locked in.
[ Drumroll ]
Legendary game show host.
[ Laughter ]
Let's bring out the coolers.
-Oh, no!
-Let's see if she was right.
Three, two, one, dump.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Audience "ohs" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is it?
-Help!
[ Cheers and applause
continue ]
-Wow, I'm sorry.
[ Fanfare ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy -- Jimmy, your cooler
was filled with guacamole.
-It certainly was.
-It was.
-Can we see that again
in slow motion, please?
-Do we need to?
I mean, this...
[ Audience gasps ]
Alright.
This is insane. Alright.
Oh, we're not done yet.
The score is
Kate, 7; Jimmy, nothing.
The next question is for Jimmy.
Jimmy?
-Yeah?
-If you can answer this.
-Yes, I hope.
-Which of these is not the name
of a former professional
football player?
Which of these is not the name
of a former professional
football player?
"A" --
-Not the name?
-Not the name, not the name.
-Mm-hmm.
"A," Woody Gobbler;
"B," Craphonso Thorpe;
or, "C," Ashton Youboty?
[ Laughter ]
-This person
is not a football player?
-They're not a football player.
-Name them again.
The first one is --
-Woody Gobbler.
-Woody Gobbler?
-Craphonso Thorpe.
-Craphonso Thorpe is
like something
from a "Harry Potter" book.
[ Light laughter ]
-And Ashton Youboty.
-This is the dumbest game
I've ever played.
You might as well
just bring out
another whipped-cream pie
or something.
It's going to be -- I think
Craphonso Forpe or whatever --
Thorpe.
-You say that the answer is --
Okay, your answer is locked in.
Let's bring out
our next round of coolers.
[ Drumroll ]
He said "B."
Let's see if he's right.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Three, two, one, dump.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Crowd cheers ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on, man.
This is insane.
This is the stupidest --
This is insane right now.
Craphonso Thorpe?
-Craphon-- That is incorrect.
The correct answer
is Woody Gobbler.
-I understand.
-Woody Gobbler was the answer.
Let's see it again.
[ Laughs ]
I want to see it again
in slow motion.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Why -- Why am I doing this?
Alright. This is unbelievable.
Kate doesn't even know anything
about American football.
And this is rigged.
-It must be.
-I'm so bad.
-The score is 14-nothing.
Kate's in the lead.
-Yeah.
-The next question
is for you, Kate.
-Are you sure?
Maybe I should answer this.
[ Light laughter ]
-Who is the oldest quarterback
to ever win a Super Bowl?
"A," Tom Brady;
BB," Peyton Manning;
"C, John Elway.
-I mean, not being funny,
I don't even really know
what a quarterback is.
[ Light laughter ]
-You've got to be kidding me.
-Sorry.
-Why don't you
take a good look at Jimmy
and then answer the question,
if you don't mind.
-I'm just going to take a guess
because Peyton Manning
sounds old.
[ Laughter ]
-Peyton Manning sounds old.
-It sounds like an old name.
-Your answer is locked in, Kate.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay.
-Let's bring out the coolers.
-Oh, no.
-Now, let's see
if Kate was right.
[ Drumroll ]
Three, two, one, dump.
[ Buzzer ]
-Aah!
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?! What?!
Absolutely not!
Absolutely [Laughing] not!
What in the -- What
are you talking about?!
You have paper leaves
dusted off her?
You look beautiful.
-They're real leaves.
They smell like fall.
[ Laughter ]
-This is absolutely --
What was the correct answer?
-The correct answer
is Tom Brady.
-Well.
-Tom Brady.
-Kate, your cooler
was filled with leaves.
Can we see that again
in slow motion?
-No, you don't even --
What's the sense?
Oh, boo-hoo.
Oh, I feel so bad for you.
-Look at how scared she is.
-Look how scared she is.
She wasn't scared.
Oh, my God.
-The score is
Kate, 14; Jimmy, 7.
[ Whistle blows ]
Oh, that whistle means it's time
for the final question.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, yeah.
It certainly is, Alec.
-And there's a twist.
This question
is worth 1,000 touchdowns.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-So anyone can still
technically win.
-There is guac in my pants.
Alright, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really garlicky, as well.
-Yeah, I know. It's disgusting.
-Oh, God.
This question is for you, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-Before 1921,
the Chicago Bears --
-Wait, wait, before 1921?
-Before 1921.
-Yeah, no problem.
I'll get this one.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
What year around-ish? Like 1914?
-Yeah, let's say,
between 1920 and 400 B.C.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever.
-Before 1921, the Chicago Bears
were known by what name?
"A," the Chicago Chicken Hawks;
the Evanston Eagles;
the Decatur Staleys.
-Hmm.
Can't phone a friend.
[ Laughter ]
-Where would you put the phone?
How would you hold the phone?
[ Laughter ]
The Chicago Chicken Hawks...
-No.
...the Evanston Eagles...
-Sure.
-...the Decatur Staleys.
Which is your answer?
-It doesn't matter, does it?
[ Laughter ]
-Bring it out
and dump something on me.
This is insane.
Or maybe bring out a blow-dryer
and have her hair blow back.
[ Laughter ]
This is insane.
I'll say the Evanston whatever,
the Eagles.
-The Evanston Eagles, Jimmy,
Your answer is locked in.
Let's bring out
the final two coolers.
-I don't know when you walk away
when this cooler comes out.
-Oh, yeah, let's bring out
the final two coolers here.
[ Drumroll ]
Let's see who the winner is.
Three, two, one, dump!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Spitting ]
What is that?
-It's Pepto-Bismol, Jimmy.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's Pepto-Bismol.
And your answer is incorrect.
The correct answer was, "C,"
the Decatur Staleys.
Which means that Kate Beckinsale
is our winner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Band plays finale ]
-The champion Kate Beckinsale,
everybody.
We'll be right back
with Alec Baldwin.
Do you really want to do that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪